bonsoir hier soir donald trump a changé
d'avis lui qui accusait ses adversaires
d'en faire trop sur le corps d'un virus
de vouloir lui nuire
en montant cette affaire en épingle
prend désormais l'épidémie très très au
sérieux
le président américain a annoncé une
série de mesures dont l'une
particulièrement spectaculaire la
fermeture des états unis à tous les
voyageurs européens et plus exactement
d'ailleurs aux voyageurs de l'espace
schengen
on écoute ça entraînait une déclaration
bien solennelle ferghana jarry ce qu'il
a raison président trump écoutez moi je
ne suis pas médecin donc je ne suis pas
capable de commenter cette mesure sur le
plan purement technique et sanitaire
maintenant effectivement de ce que je
lis les avis sont assez partagés puisque
ce virus étant déjà sur le sol américain
d'où l'embarras et que leurs barricades
et élise exclusivement l'europe par
l'espace schengen en exemptant le
royaume uni ça dénote quand même une
certaine cohérence ce que beaucoup
disent en réalité c'est que ceux qui
s'attaquent à un co et rance plutôt les
sens et cohérent c'est à dire que ou
bien on
voilà on estime que l'europe est un
foyer infectieux est dans toute l'europe
devrait être condamnée mais fait
d'épargner uniquement les britanniques
ça donc ça ça des documents une certaine
incohérence est ce que les expertises
c'est que ce virus est temps aujourd'hui
déjà sur place en réalité la distinction
étrangers locale n'a plus beaucoup de
sens c'est à dire qu'il va falloir que
les américains fassent attention aussi
entre eux plutôt que de penser que le
danger serait là exclusivement étrangers
donc moi j'ai l'impression que donald
trump vers 6,6 dans une outrance parce
que on lui a reproché pendant très
longtemps de minimiser le risque de dire
tout va bien regarder n'y a pas à
s'inquiéter
là il se rend compte que la situation
semble un petit peu
donc pour contrer les critiques de
laxisme il vient en outre ans mais dans
les deux cas je ne pense pas que ça
changera grand chose
alexandre ii vecchio est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça est ce que c'est
la faute aux européens finalement une
deuxième chinois président c'est pas la
faute de personne un petit peut-être
quand même de l'achille parce que il ya
des conditions sanitaires là bas ou qui
sont dénoncées depuis longtemps et rien
n'est fait pour ce qui est de l'europe
c'est pas de la faute de l'europe mais
le président américain prend on prend
des mesures pour protéger son peuple
ça paraît pas non plus totalement
aberrant effectivement il ya cette
incohérence avec eux le royaume uni
plutôt que de décréter des mesures de
confinement
ce sera peut-être nécessaire aussi aux
états unis éviter qu'il ne circulent
trop sa part être aussi quelque chose de
ne pas forcément idiot je crois que ça
dérange notamment en europe puisque cela
pose la question des frontières
parce que ces deux crises la finir par
poser cette question là on voit que
qu'elles sont de retour et seront de
retour dans l'économie elles sont de
retour de manière dure par la question
des voyageurs de tourisme etc
c'est c'est un débat finalement d'avenir
on croyait qu'elle était dépassé et bien
elles reviennent voilà après moi je ne
suis pas médecin en médecin non plus
mais je suppose que s'il le fait c'est
pas pour pas pour rien vu les
conséquences économiques que ça peut
attendre l'examen n'a finalement
effectivement poutine et annie autres up
est ce que ce n'est pas un mouvement
inéluctable
en tout cas ça confirme que les états
unis sont en mesure de prendre des
décisions que les pays d'europe et
l'europe ne savent pas prendre ça lui
prend ça il ya il ya une capacité de
prise de décisions par forcément
toujours très bien considérer mais qui
est qui est réel après est ce que c'est
une bonne décision quand on voit la
réaction des marchés financiers
aujourd'hui et est ce que c'est en train
de coûter et provoquer en cascade sur
les questions économiques et financières
on peut se poser la question des racines
voilà souhaitable que certaines bulle se
dégonfle un peu c'est pas idiot que la
bourse ait foncé pas certain qu'on sache
exactement ça nous amène il aurait pu
prendre une mesure d'entre eux deux
c'est évidemment pas passer d'une
logique du tout ou à rien avec une
interdiction totale et brutale de tous
les voyageurs mais peut-être vraiment
encouragé tiers non oui mais peut-être
que la la la la la panique aurait
peut-être été moindre si on avait dit
aux gens écoutent et voilà on est dans
une situation de crise on ne sait
coordonnées 15 européen
on recommande une limitation extrême de
tous les voyages on n'interdit pas ce
qui est nécessaire au bon fonctionnement
l'économie on met en place des mesures
de protection
on s'organise un petit peu comme l'ont
fait les chinois mais en tout cas on
essaie on est vite s'ils voulaient de
passer d'un d'une logique ce qui promet
des demi mesures phares la semaine ce
qui explique aussi que les américains
n'est pas interdit les relations de
trafic aérien avec la chine parce que
les chinois dès le départ ont en effet
pris des mesures extrêmement drastiques
mais un moment donné il faut aussi
savoir si on peut trouver un équilibre
entre la protection des uns et des
autres et en même temps le fait qu'il
faut éviter comptons dans un chaos
économique parce que derrière les
conséquences sociales seront peut-être
bien pire que les conséquences
sanitaires
peut-être intéressant de voir la
réaction de trump une fois que ce virus
circulera aux etats-unis est-ce qu'on va
fermer les frontières des états déjà
est-ce qu'on va fermer contient des
états exactement il fait de la politique
qui fait porter la responsabilité de la
diffusion du virus sur le sol américain
aux étrangers c'est sur la peur de
l'étranger la peur de l'autre
il est en campagne électorale et il faut
absolument qu'ils se dédouane que ce qui
va se passer ici prenait des mesures
sanitaires il empêcherait il limiterait
la propagation du virus au sein des
états unis alors qu'il circule déjà en
limitant les vols domestiques déjà mais
de manière moins importante que chez
nous en france on peut jour il ya
beaucoup plus de cas là bas que je
connais mais on paye et on peut imaginer
que la circulation fin que ça circule en
plus par l'extérieur
c'est un facteur aggravant alors ils
jugent politiquement effectivement il
est moins coûteux de de fermer les
frontières que de mettre en place des
mesures c'est reporté l'agréable
stabilité sur l'extérieur c'est plus
facile passe comme ça si il se dédouane
demande à ce qu'on prenne des mesures
économiques il dit au congrès fait
baisser les taxes sur les salaires pour
relancer le pouvoir d'achat des gens qui
sont impactés et on peut s'y dit c'est
la faute de l'étranger puisque le virus
arrive de l'europe
donc il se dit moi j'ai fait ce que
j'avais à faire en plus je demande à ce
qu'une mobilisation générale pour qu'on
trouve un vaccin très très vie qui dit
moi je fais mon job et les électeurs
jugeront
le problème c'est que c'est pas ça qui
va arrêter la diffusion du virus qui est
déjà aux états unis et qui va se
propager
parce qu'il se propage aujourd'hui est
beaucoup plus vite que ceux qui se
protègent en europe et notamment en
france
est-ce qu'il ya pas de lecture
finalement on s'y attendait l'iphone
disait ben c'est pas une crise
européenne est une crise mondiale et
c'est ça que réfute donald trump
mais c'est une crise mondiale est la
meilleure preuve c'est qu'en fermant ses
frontières il reconnaît que c'est venu
aussi aux états unis et que ça peut
continuer à venir et c'est pas il c'est
pas les états unis sont pas unis
laisseront pas d'isoler du monde qui est
dommage là encore ça confirme que la
régulation mondiale la gouvernance
mondiale fonctionne pas on jeudi gilles
je pense que donne un top napper
personnes en europe la lie cette nuit il
a fallu tu en voilà ça prend du temps
d'allah allah donc personne est prévu
tout le monde découvre en séance la
réalité donc forcément pas de panique
pour qu'avec c'est vrai qu'avec des
ailiers pareil on n'a pas vraiment un
ennemi a été le programme america first
il est un peu de coordination
internationale gère ne serait ce que
dans une logique de partage avec les
chefs d'état européens s'en fou oui mais
ce serait peut être plus efficace ne
serait ce que d'un but
d'accord c'est que la politique mais il
s'est passé pas laisser quelqu'un qui
recherche il cherche à les traverser
d'attendre qu'il y aurait peut-être pu
prendre cette mesure avant même j'ai
envie de dire et les européens si il
était en capacité d'agir parce que ce
scam hausse et montre encore une fois
c'est que donald trump ou même bassin
laitier qui jumelle et cap
alors on l'écouté effectivement vous
mettez en avant l'aspect économique on
écoute sur l'aspect économique sur les
mesures qu'elle compte mettre en avant
tout une chose a été coupé par donald
trump continuer ça confirme ce que je
disais on peut aimer ou pas aimé sa
politique mais il fait de la politique
est là les moyens de tous les leviers
d'action la frontière d'un côté un plan
de relance immédiat dans une économie
qui était contre moi à la nôtre atone
mais qui le prolonge et qu'il accélère
donc voir quelqu'un qui est pleinement
aux commandes on voit effectivement des
dirigeants européens qui ne qu'ils ne
sont pas et là où il ya peut-être une
faute politique c'est justement ne pas
avoir fermé les frontières assez tôt
notamment avec la chine
parce que là au départ on aura peut-être
pu imaginer que le diffus le levier se
diffuse quand même moins vite et qu'on
limite sa propagation donc voilà mais je
crois qu'on est à la fin d'un cycle
à la fin de l'idée alors ça va peut-être
avoir des conséquences financières
traduire justement mais je crois qu'on
est à un système à bout de souffle ou
vont pensais que c'était le marché qui
faisait la politique est aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que ce que ce n'est pas le
cas donc on est à mon avis dans un
changement de paradigme qui était déjà
entre enfin arrivé avec le break site
avec donald trump et c est que le
coronavirus ne fait qu'accélérer
woerth à fait d'accord c'est à dire que
l'un de nos plus grands espoirs quand
même pour la résolution de cette crise
et que les marchés précisément les
industries les labos pharmaceutiques
mettent au point des médicaments des
vaccins des rétrovirus et ceci le plus
rapidement possible or je vois mal
comment ces solutions à deviendront sans
coopération internationale on oublie
aussi que l' avantage de ces marchés
mondialisés que l'on décrit aujourd'hui
pour faire la frontière qu'on peut pas
tromper ramé soit le précisément à dire
que évidemment donc on est d'accord je
fait que la coopération nationale est
souhaitable et que ce n'est pas en
fantasmant à un repli que l'on va et on
m'en parlait tout à l'heure
le simple fait que la chine aujourd'hui
puissent exporter du matériel médical en
italie est aussi un signe que les
interdépendances et les rapports
commerciaux permettent aussi aux
sociétés humaines d'être plus résiliente
lorsqu'elles sont victimes de pénuries
de médicaments de matériel
je ne pense pas que ce soit la fin d'un
cycle je pense qu'après cette crise les
choses vont se normaliser les chaînes
d'approvisionnement vont se reconstituer
parce que personne n'a intérêt à se
soustraire au commerce mondial et ceci
même dans l'adversité ne portent pas
toujours et qu'après une crise comme
celle là quand elle s'arrêtera quand on
aura fini de la règle et sur un plan
sanitaire
voilà il y aura il y aura deux façons
plusieurs scénarios et rappelons-nous
alors l'histoire se répète parfois il ya
un siècle on a ouvert à partir de 1920
le début des années folles et on sait où
ça nous a conduits vous avez plusieurs
options
les réactions nationales en chine en
europe et aux états unis sur la
responsabilité tout ça peut-être
accentue l logique nationaliste et leurs
prix et le repli est très un très très
mauvais un vecteur d'avenir on risque de
se retrouver les inscrits contre désolé
mais c'est un risque non mais beaucoup
plus grave parce qu'à terme il peut
amener à des véritables confrontation
donc il ya peut-être une opportunité
après cette crise qui consistait
justement essayer donc pas de faire ce
que fait domaine de lindre homme s'est
lui dit les l'unilatéralisme pardon
brutal mais désistement d'inventer de
nouveaux concepts notamment fondée sur
la réciprocité pour éviter par exemple
de cesser de produire des médicaments en
chine et les rapatrier en europe de
continuer à avoir des partenariats des
deals avec des pays comme la chine mais
pas fondées sur ce déséquilibre actuel
dire qu'aujourd'hui nous les européens
on est des grands perdants de tous on se
fait avoir par les américains on se fait
avoir par les chinois donc il ya
peut-être un principe à inventer
attendant l'indépendance
oui mais il ya une logique de galard
penser parce que sinon on va aller vers
les affrontements à terme inéluctable
mais le fascine n'est pas le repli que
de vouloir retrouver un minimum
d'indépendance un minimum d'industrie
nationale d'autonomie de patriotisme
économique
non ça c'est d'une vision en globaliste
des choses j'ai envie de dire qu'on peut
avoir un monde ouvert avec des états qui
coopère mais qui reste des étapes rives
des états souverains avec leur propre
industrie avec leurs propres à 4 mm les
industries c'est à dire que l' avantage
d'avoir quand même le les avantages
comparatifs et une division tentation du
travail c'est précisément la capacité de
l'industrie à fournir des services à une
échelle massive et damien la plus
compétitive possible donc relocaliser
des industries pourquoi pas mais si
c'est pour payer nos buts nos
médicaments aux trois à quatre fois plus
cher je ne suis pas certain qu'on y
gagne au change peut-être que pour
l'instant il faut régler ces crises
sanitaires l'évaluer en mesurer les
conséquences économiques et à prévoir
quel monde il en découle dans des
couloirs et quel paradigme il faudra
changer ou pas pour l'instant il ya des
morts il ya donc on verra après quel est
le meilleur monde dans lequel vivre en
fonction des frontières ou pas des
frontières il faut l'anticiper
oui peut-être commencé à prêcher savent
aller vite une question actuelle à bord
les morts non mais c'est une question
qui doit dire que pour des marchés c'est
une question actuelle c'est à dire que
pour encore une fois démocratiser
l'accès aux médicaments qui permettront
de résoudre cette crise
mon ami ne faut pas oublier que le
commerce mondial est mon élection et ne
travaille plus donald trump toute façon
à partir moment il n'a pas forcément la
capacité haut sur le sol américain de
co2 faire les choses tout seul il ira
chercher l'aide là où il en a besoin
pour le peuple américain parce que
america first toute façon là ça sera le
pragmatisme qui l'emportera au delà de
la fermeture ou pas des frontières alors
sur le site les internautes no10 trump a
totalement raison le s'occupe de son
peuple mon regret c'est que notre
dirigeant ne fasse pas de même pragma
nous disent que réciproquement les
européens interdisent l'entrée de
l'europe aux américains les bas est
assez partagée je vais vous dire comme
cette dernière phrase qu'avait déclaré
donald trump hier soir l'amérique relève
toujours les défis et riom de
l'adversité notre futur reste plus
radieux qu'on lui imagine en agissant
avec compassion et amour nous allons
guérir les malades tous là je ceux dans
le besoin d'aider nos compatriotes et
nous sortirons de cette épreuve plus
forts et plus unis que jamais ça si
c'est pas du volontariat était pour moi
alors vous étiez en vous étiez en plein
déjà dans notre deuxième question c'est
cette bien dit
ici une mission que celle de